OK.
For the second day in a row, exactly as the
time lag hypothesis would predict.
Texas set another single day death record
yesterday.
Remember that cases started spiking in Texas
around mid to later June, like June 16th to
18th.
We anticipate typically a 19 to 21 day lag
time between cases and deaths.
And so if cases tart the spike between June
16 and 18, we would expect deaths to spike
right now.
And that's exactly what happened.
We had a then single day death record in Texas
of 85 deaths on Tuesday and then yesterday,
an even bigger number of 50 percent bigger.
One hundred and twenty one deaths yesterday.
So this does not bode well for the next 10
days because of the new cases were actually
twice as high last week in Texas than they
were back in mid-June.
Very, very ugly.
Also notable that Florida, the other state,
along with Arizona and California, that's
seeing huge numbers of cases.
Florida today, as of noon, had already gotten
a new single day death record only as of noon.
So things are looking very, very bad.
Now, meanwhile, in Oklahoma, you might remember
that Donald Trump had a rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
a couple of weeks ago.
Oklahoma set a new case record yesterday with
eight hundred and fifty eight cases in one
day, which probably is not coming as a shock
to too many people.
So what's important about this is that when
we saw the cases start to spike, but not the
deaths, the most easy explanation, the most
easy, the easiest argument to make was there's
a lag between cases and deaths.
It's about 20 days.
There were other ideas thrown out.
And I've mentioned some of these ideas to
you before.
It's it's younger people getting the virus.
So the deaths aren't going to spike because
young people tend not to be as affected by
the virus.
We're doing more testing, meaning that on
average, the people being tested are healthier.
So even though there are more cases being
reported, we're not actually going to see
as many as many people die.
States could be lying.
And it's still not clear that states are being
totally transparent.
And, you know, all these different ideas,
the virus has mutated and become less serious.
It's sadly and tragically is looking more
and more like the explanation is the simplest
one, which is cases started going up sometime
between June 16 and June 20, depending on
the state.
And 20 days later, which is now, we're starting
to see the deaths spike.
Now, meanwhile and I'm going to have more
coverage of this on tomorrow's program.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump wants kids back in
school.
He wants all kids back in school in person,
despite the medical community saying this
isn't safe, despite public health officials
expressing concern about sending all kids
back to school, despite a number of summer
camps having to be shut down because so many
people, so many kids have gotten the virus,
including I believe it's Arkansas, Missouri
and one other state at least, has had the
shut down summer camps.
And the projection coming out of Donald Trump's
mouth lately is truly stunning.
He said earlier this week that states are
keeping politically are keeping schools closed
for political reasons.
He even tweeted yesterday, quote, In Germany,
Denmark, Norway, Sweden and many other countries,
schools are open with no problems.
The Dems think it would be bad for them politically
if U.S. schools open before the November election,
but is important for the children and families.
May cut off funding if not open now.
Sweden aside, Sweden's having problems.
The other countries Trump mentions dealt with
coronavirus.
The reason that schools are opening in those
countries is they have so few cases.
Germany, Denmark and Norway had at most a
couple hundred or new cases a day recently,
or even like in the teens, are just double
digits.
We have 60000 new cases a day.
So if you want to be doing what Europe is
doing, you should have handled corona virus
like Europe did from the beginning.
Now, I also can't ignore that Donald Trump
is threatening schools with pulling funding
if they don't open Trump.
Said he doesn't want to make this political.
He said that earlier this week, he says he
believes schools are being kept closed for
political reasons.
But Trump has identified that he believes
schools are being kept kept close to hurt
him.
So Trump is now saying we don't want to make
it political, but we're going to force you
to reopen schools under penalty of pulling
funding because he believes it will help his
reelection if schools are open.
That's making it political, which he claims
schools are actually doing.
Consider also this incredible hypocrisy.
If it's too dangerous for Paul Manafort and
Michael Cohen to be in prison because of Corona
virus, how is it safe to reopen every school?
And I know some of you will say, but David.
Michael Cohen is not an old guy, but he's
older than kids.
Paul Manafort is even older.
I think Manafort is in his 70s.
Kids are not as at risk when it comes to spreading.
And serious cases of coronaviruses people,
Paul Manafort, say.
That is true.
But what about the teachers?
What about the parents?
And tens of millions of children going back
to school are going to put millions of adults
at risk.
And and I want to be really clear.
I get economically the importance of opening
schools.
A lot of parents can't work if their kids
aren't in school because they can't just for
childcare.
So even if every single day, you know, full
time childcare.
So even if the job has reopened for the parent,
they may be unable to work if their kids aren't
in school.
I get it.
But we have to be sensible.
If schools had to close when there were 100000
active cases in the United States, how can
you say they should open when we have a million
and a half active cases in the United States,
which is roughly where we are estimated to
be right now?
I'm struggling with the math of it.
And tomorrow on the program at the top of
the show tomorrow because of the Supreme Court
decision on Trump's taxes, we just ran out
of time.
Tomorrow, we're going to talk more about the
case for opening or not opening schools.
Hey, this
is really funny.